l'hebdo politique bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous du dimanche soir sur radio
sensations en association avec tv sont
18 épisodes 207 mon invité ce soir et le
député de l'essonne cédric villani
[Musique]
les politiques
cédric villani bonsoir bonsoir courante
et un zoo vous êtes député de la 5e
circonscription de l'essonne et
conseiller du 14e arrondissement de
paris pour vous présenter rapidement
j'ai retenu quatre temps forts dans
votre parcours au mathématicien d'abord
en 2010 vous remporter la médaille
fields une récompense extrêmement
prestigieuse dans le domaine des
mathématiques vous vous lancer en
politique lors des élections
législatives en 2017 vous êtes élue
députée sous l'étiquette la république
en marche vous symbolisez à l'époque
cette nouvelle vague de la société
civile vient ensuite le moment où vous
présenter aux élections municipales en
2020 à paris alors que la république en
marche avait choisi benjamin griveaux
vous êtes par la suite exclu du parti de
la majorité présidentielle et parvenait
à être élu conseiller municipal dans le
14e arrondissement
2021 enfin vous devenez porte-parole de
delphine batho présidente de génération
écologie dans le cadre de la campagne
pour la primaire écologiste vous avez
toujours refusé vous de vous classer
politiquement à droite à gauche ou au
centre aujourd'hui le pôle écologiste
c'est la famille politique avec laquelle
vous vous partagez le plus de valeur
aujourd'hui et ça je vous parle
d'expérience de ce que j'ai pu voir dans
les débats à l'assemblée nationale et
dans les bas politique en général c'est
clairement au pôle écologiste que je
dans ce pôle a que je me retrouve
génération écologie se définit ni gauche
ni droite élevé se définira sans doute
comme gauche mais l'un et l'autre font
partie de ce pôle écologiste qui a comme
valeur fondamentale
le fait de promouvoir une transition
écologique forte très axée sur des
grands combats comme le la baisse de
l'empreinte carbone la condition animale
la disparition des pesticides autant que
possible et c est aussi le fédéralisme
européen je me permets par rapport au
petit portrait que vous avez brossé
d'apporter une petite rectification
je me suis lancé dans la politique en ce
sens en 2010 juste après la médaille
fields quand je suis devenu vice
président d'europanova groupe de
réflexion laboratoire d'idées ou think
tank appelez le comme vous voulez
fédéraliste européen
dans lequel j'ai milité des années
durant c'est ce qui m'a amené entre
autres à être membre du conseil
scientifique de la commission européenne
pendant des années en tant que
mathématicien mais aussi en tant que
quelqu'un qui croit fondamentalement
dans la construction européenne qui
pensent que c'est l'enjeu politique le
plus important de notre temps avec la
révolution écologique et qui se définit
toujours comme fédéraliste alors comme
vous le savez c'est yannick jadot qui a
remporté la primaire écologiste vous
soutenez donc sa candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
absolument j'étais porte parole de
delphine batho en pour la fête primaire
des écologistes
avec delphine batho nos parcours
politique sont extrêmement différents ce
n'était pas prévu au départ que nous
puissions nous rencontrer et puis on a
été l'un comme l'autre
parmi les créateurs les fondateurs de ce
groupe parlementaire à l'assemblée
cologie démocratie solidarité qui a été
le groupe parlementaire écologiste à
l'assemblée pendant les quelques mois où
on a été actif en tant que groupe
parlementaire on a pu porter défendre
des dossiers à fort contenu écologiques
comme le combat contre les
néonicotinoïdes où la proposition de loi
que j'ai portée pour une des avancées
sur la condition animale en particulier
la fin de l'élevage intensif à sur à
l'horizon d'une génération
et puis après on a été très impliquée
même après la même une fois qu'on était
plus qu'un petit noyau d'une dizaine de
députés très très impliqué très très
actif
sur le projet de loi climat résilience
en particulier organisé de grands débats
en switch pour faire connaître autant
que possible les enjeux qui sont
derrière donc on à être extrêmement bien
accroché avec delphine batho je me suis
retrouvé dans sa façon d'aller au fond
des dossiers son courage sa
détermination sa façon très pointue
d'aborder les débats et on a été en
grande confiance de sorte que je quand
j'ai su qu'elle se lançait la première
des écologistes j'ai tout de suite
manifestez l'envi de la rejoindre elle à
soutenir je suis devenu son porte parole
nous avons reconnu la victoire de
yannick jadot sans aucun problème et
nous sommes maintenant en soutien de sa
candidature pour le moment selon les
sondages à ninja 2 dépasse toujours pas
les 10% est ce que ça vous inquiète en
vue de l'élection présidentielle vous
dire j'ai passé une élection municipale
voudrais rappeler quelques étapes mais
en quelques minutes on peut pas décrire
une élection municipale qui était aussi
chaotique aussi longue aussi aussi
complexe et
une des choses que j'ai retenu de ces
élections municipales c'est qu'on a
accordé beaucoup beaucoup trop
d'attention aux sondages et qu'ils ont
miné complètement le débat politique de
fond on a beaucoup plus parlé pendant
cette municipale de savoir s'il y avait
calé car il peut y avoir entre les
différents candidats et commencent à
évoluer que de propositions de fond
comme par exemple celle que je portais
que je considère qu'ils aient toujours
majeur pour l'avenir de paris le fait
que paris s'agrandisse le fait que paris
aille progressivement occupé tout le
périmètre qui aujourd'hui occupé par la
petite couronne ne serait ce que pour
être en cohérence par rapport au bassin
de vie bassin d'activités que paris
s'intègre beaucoup mieux dans la dent
dans la région avec de meilleures
connexions avec l'essonne de meilleures
connexions et crise yvelines et ainsi de
suite et j'aurais été heureux qu'on
parle beaucoup plus ces questions de
fond que des questions de ce sondage
dans le débat de la présidentielle qui
nous occupe ça commence aussi on a des
sondages presque tous les jours c'est
une orgie de sondage la france est et
drogué aux sondages et je ne vais pas
les commenter bon boulot aujourd'hui
dans cette campagne c'est de parler des
enjeux qui me tiennent à coeur
transition énergétique la cause animale
l'agriculture les pesticides la façon
dont pourra combiner les révolutions
technologiques avec les révolutions
écologique le changement de société que
ça représente et je m'en tiendrai là
alors dans l'actualité politique il y à
ce week-end la fin de la coop 26 qui
vient de se terminer à glasgow alors les
négociations devraient toujours être en
cours une conférence donc c'est là qu'au
26 et une conférence internationale sous
l'égide des nations unies sur les
conséquences du changement climatique
alors est ce que cette réunion est
encore quelque chose d'utile selon
le simple fait que les chefs d'état ou
leurs représentants se réunisse et
discute on va pas dire que c'est quelque
chose de mal pas maintenant depuis des
années ces grandes réunions cecop donne
des résultats décevant très décevant
malgré l'accord de paris les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre n'ont pas
diminué c'est le contraire elles ont
augmenté les engagements de réduction
pris par la communauté nationale ne sont
pas du tout à la hauteur c'est les
engagements c'est une petite fraction
ridicule de ce qu'il faudrait faire de
ce qui avait été envisagé comme promesse
d'ailleurs dans la sortie de l'accord de
paris est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
aussi c'est que sur certains des grands
rendez vous les engagements ne sont pas
là des jeux pensait td 2009 les coop
avait acté le fait qu'il fallait des
grandes de dd grande aide des pays
riches vers les pays démunis pour
affronter la transition climatique pour
affronter le réchauffement climatique on
parlait de 100 milliards à l'échelle
mondiale comme du grand grand minimum en
vrai si sans doute mille milliards qu'il
faudrait ou quelque chose comme ça
aujourd'hui on est loin de ces 100
milliards les engagements des pays
riches ne sont pas à la hauteur les
engagements pour sortir des fossés des
énergies fossiles ne sont pas à la
hauteur bref l'expression degré tatum
berg à a fait florès et a été reprise
partout mais elle décrit très bien ce
qui se passe en priorité dans ces
grandes coop bla bla bla nous étions
dimanche dernier présent lors de la
marche climat à paris qui lui demandait
des mesures efficaces afin de mieux
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique quels sont aujourd'hui les
revendications des des gens qui étaient
à cette manifestation et est ce que vous
avez pu échanger avec d'autres personnes
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui en est ressorti
ça fait un moment qu'on commence à avoir
marché ça fait de nombreuses marches
qu'ont effectué les revendications elles
sont là elles sont sur la table elles
sont pas mystérieuse et elles
correspondent d'ailleurs assez bien à ce
que proposer les
citoyens de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat les 149 citoyens qui avaient
fait un tout un ensemble de propositions
citoyens tirés au sort au début pas
spécialement plus conscients des
questions des enjeux climatiques que
quiconque mais qui à force de travail et
de réfléchir de discuter avec les
scientifiques en était arrivé à des
positions très très engageante sur le
climat et qui portait sur la réduction
du trafic aérien qui portait sur une des
rénovations thermiques beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup plus ample beaucoup
plus rapide qui portait sur l'évolution
de la mobilité qui portait sur les
questions agricoles sur le fait de
réduire drastiquement leurs usages
d'engrais de synthèse qui portait sur le
fait de sortir des énergies fossiles et
ainsi de suite toutes ces propositions
là on peut les répéter l'erreur répéter
elles sont pas mystérieuse elles ont été
portées par beaucoup beaucoup de voix
maintenant ce sont juste celle là que
nous réclamons quand il y avait ce
projet de loi climat résilience qui
passait à l'assemblée nationale c'était
une oie fleuve le plus long débat est la
plus longue loi qu'on ait discuté durant
toute cette tous mandat à l'assemblée
nationale il y avait peut-être 200
articles en comptant les bcae les terres
nous on n'en demandait pas tant on
demandait juste une dizaine d'articles
efficace on l'a écrit on a été écrit une
contre proposition de loi avec des gens
comme matthieu orphelin delphine batho
et autres on l'appelait la vraie loi
climat pas une loi très longue mais une
loi efficace c'est ce genre de choses
qu'on réclame alors dans les faits des
engagements ont tout de même été pris
lors de cette coop par exemple 190 pays
étaient engagés je vous arrête tout de
suite à l'accord de paris vous souvenez
cette grand messe d d d d accord de tous
les pays du monde ou presque avec la
france avec laurent fabius aux
négociateurs des engagements des
promesses ont été prises elles n'ont pas
été tenues les promesses ne suffisent
plus on veut maintenant des actes visent
blanc en cours d'émission de gaz à effet
de serre alors on va passer maintenant à
un autre thème depuis vous avez rejoint
delphine batho vague donc génération
écologie vous défendez le projet de
décroissance parce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce que c'est que cette notion
de décroissance on n'est pas ici d'abord
j'ai insisté sur un thème qui est comme
une nouvelle conversion pour moi même si
j'étais moins explicite dans les
formules quand vous regardez le rapport
sur l'intelligence artificielle que j'ai
rendu en 2018 au gouvernement j'ai été
très clair sur le fait que les
trajectoires aujourd'hui dans le secteur
du numérique par rapport à la
consommation énergétique par rapport à
la consommation de matières premières ne
sont pas soutenables et qu'il faut
forcément arriver vers quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sobre économe le projet
décroissance c'est cela est appliqué à
l'ensemble des questions sociétales à
dire que premièrement le produit
intérieur brut le pib n'est pas un
indicateur pertinent aujourd'hui pour
résoudre les défis de société parce que
aujourd'hui
plus vous avez de voitures polluantes
mieux c'est pour le pib plus vous avez
de catastrophes auxquelles il faut
apporter des solutions technologiques
mieux si pour le pib une grande épidémie
qui entraîne une très grande activité de
production de médicaments c'est bon pour
le pib s'est pas de ça que nous avons
besoin élevage intensif avec la
surconsommation la surproduction de
produits de agricoles produits d'élevage
c'est bon pour le pib et c'est pas ça
qui va mieux pour la planète le pib
mondial depuis des années voire des
décennies il est très bien corrélé à la
quantité d'énergie que nous utilisons
dans le monde il ya des courbes
extrêmement c'est quasiment une droite
la corrélation entre u2 fait partie de
ce qu'elle m'a rappelé jean marc
jancovici grandes figures de la sur le
lieu du chief project et plus
généralement sur les réflexions de
comment la société doit diminuer son
empreinte carbone et la réduire
quasiment à zéro et c'est cette
exploitation d'énergie consommation
aujourd'hui un peu partout dans le monde
ça vient avec la destruction de
l'environnement la destruction de
ressources fossiles la destruction de
deux gisements de minerais ça vient avec
toutes sortes de conséquences mauvaises
pour la planète des économistes comme
eloi laurent ou vincent liegey où
timothée parick qui sont des
spécialistes de la décroissance depuis
des années explique et démonte ouvrage
après ouvrage pourquoi le pib est une
fausse valeur pourquoi aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de prendre en compte aussi
l'impact environnemental l'impact
sociétal et pourquoi aujourd'hui c'est
un enjeu majeur que de réduire notre
empreinte sur la consommation sur
l'exploitation des ressources des
ressources naturelles en même temps que
le monde a vu le pib grimper grimper
grimper
le monde a vu aussi la biodiversité
diminué diminué diminue de façon
dramatique
aujourd'hui les animaux sauvages
ça représente sur la par rapport à
l'ensemble des des vertébrés terrestres
4 % de la biomasse 4% le reste c'est
quoi les humains les animaux domestiques
et surtout les animaux d'élevage
aujourd'hui la majorité produit alors
accessoirement mais c'est pas accessoire
le plus souvent dans des conditions qui
sont horribles des conditions de
barbarie de torture par rapport à evans
en cage eva intensif entassement des
poulets entassement des lapins
entassement des cochons et ainsi de
suite tout ça certes ça contribue au pib
mais c'est aussi de la surproduction
c'est aussi de la pollution
supplémentaire c'est une trajectoire
soutenable et la décroissance c'est une
âme au choc visant à ouvrir le débat
pour dire de quoi avons nous besoin
cessons de surproduire être surconsommer
cessons de dégrader la planète de façon
aveugle
interrogeons nous sur ce dont nous avons
besoin dans une réflexion de sobriété
dans cette semaine emmanuel macron a
annoncé la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires
on imagine que vous êtes plutôt déçus
par cette annonce alors soyons très
clairs
aujourd'hui le débat sur nucléaire il
est plus complexe qui ne pouvait l'être
il ya seulement dix ans ou 20 ans vous
écoutez un jean marc jancovici et vous
explique que le nucléaire doit faire
partie du du mix pour le pour une
énergie décarbonée vous en avez d'autres
qui vous disent que non ce n'est pas
indispensable
nous avons eu une très belle étude très
fouillée très détaillée effectuée par
rte des années de travail une
méthodologie qui a été
jamais vu un thé simuler toutes les des
conditions météorologiques sur des
décennies à venir pour vérifier
différents scénarios avec six scénarios
qui ont sont sortis présenté aux
décideurs des scénarios qui viennent
avec une fin du nucléaire soit en 2050
soit en 2060 et des scénarios qui
viennent avec du nucléaire qui continue
sur une trajectoire un mix important
avec jusqu'à 50 % du mix à horizon 2050
donc d'abord rte nous dit il y à des
solutions avec nucléaire il ya des
solutions sans nucléaire dans un horizon
à venir et nous dit aussi ça correspond
à des choix ça correspond aussi à des
paris par exemple dans le scénario sans
nucléaire scénario dans la terminologie
de rte c'est le scénario n 0 qui est
plus ambitieux par rapport à la sortie
nucléaire sortie nucléaire en 2050 mais
qui demande une niveau de progrès et
d'innovation au niveau des renouvelables
considérables et qui demande une volonté
d'implantation des renouvelables qui est
plus forte que celle que font même les
pays les plus vertueux la manière dont
il dit c'est possible maintenant c'est
quoi le boulot une fois que vous avez
une étude comme ça c'est le débat public
le débat parlementaire et nous à
l'office parlementaire scientifique que
je préside l'office parlementaire 110
comment parler mais nous avons organisé
des heures d'audition de rte et pour
démêler qu'est ce qui est possible qu
est-ce qu il ait pas nucléaire dans
quelles conditions nous avons aussi fait
toute une étude sur les stratégies
nucléaire possible pour la france je dis
pas ce tas mais je dis possible petit
réacteur modulaire laisser mer ou pas
des épées air ou pas quel problème avec
les 1 quels problèmes avec les autres on
a pu constater qu'ils aient de grandes
difficultés stratégique pour la france
aujourd'hui nucléaire y compris dans la
recherche le boulot maintenant de l'état
si pour en démocratie selon moi pour moi
c'est un débat parlementaire et un débat
de société que le président arrive ils
me disent j'ai décidé cette construction
pour moi ce n'est pas un fonctionnement
normal démocratique ça renvoie peut-être
à l'image du général de gaulle qui de
façon verticale
décidé on va lancer telle filière en
valence était filière mais ce n'est pas
la conception que je me fais de la
démocratie à génération écologie nous
sommes pour la sortie du
présidentialisme pour l'arrivée vers un
régime réellement parlementaire dans
lequel le pain le gouvernement tient sa
légitimité du parlement gouvernement
avec un point ministry s'occupe de
gouverner des choix stratégiques et pas
comme si aujourd'hui un régime inversée
dans lequel la majorité parlementaire
tire sa légitimité du président et donc
c'est ça que je regrette
fondamentalement dans cette annonce elle
est vertical elle ne fait aucun cas des
études qui ont été qui ont été produites
et qui appelle des débats parlementaires
et débats de société j'aimerais parler à
présent de votre proposition de loi ceux
concernant julian assange
le journaliste qui avait fondé le site
de révélations wikileaks
il est aujourd'hui toujours emprisonnés
au royaume uni dans le 24 février
prochain son procès en extradition
débutera donc aux états unis où il est
accusé notamment d'avoir révélé des
documents américains secrets il encourt
jusqu'à 105 15 ans de prison alors avec
des députés de tous bords politiques
vous demander à ce que la france lui
accorde l'asile
pourquoi avoir fait cette proposition de
loi
cette poussette proposition de
résolution pour accorder le droit
d'asile à julian assange elle sert
plusieurs buts d'abord il ya un but
humanitaire aujourd'hui julian assange
c'est un être humain qui après avoir
passé sept années de sa vie reclus dans
l'ambassade d'équateur à londres pour
éviter l'extradition cette année
sans pouvoir sortir
s'y retrouver placé par le gouvernement
britannique dans une prison de haute
sécurité qui devrait être réservé aux
terroristes les plus dangereux où il est
aujourd'hui et depuis deux ans à
l'isolément complet 23 heures sur 24 et
site vous représenter ce que ça veut
dire il ya de quoi devenir fou c'est ni
plus ni moins que de la torture et le
rapporteur spécial de l'onu sur la
torture nice mazères l'a qualifiée de
torture et aps qu'il soit libéré il est
détenu dans des conditions inhumaines et
de façon arbitraire pourquoi est ce
qu'il est ainsi persécuté depuis plus de
dix ans par les etats-unis et par la
grande bretagne qui en l'occurrence se
fait le relais servile des états unis
parce que avec wikileaks il a mis au
jour exposé des centaines de milliers de
documents qui dans l'esprit de
l'administration américaine devait
rester confidentielle des documents très
embarrassants sur certains actes qui
sont déroulées pendant la guerre
d'afghanistan pendant la guerre d'irak y
compris des massacres sur des actes
d'espionnage c'est julian assange qui a
révélé que le gouvernement américain a
espionné trois présidents américains
français successifs président chirac le
président hollande le président sarkozy
c'est julian assange qui a révélé que
des ministres de l'économie ont été ont
été espionnées aussi c'était moscovici
sté baroin j'ai donne dans le désormais
vous remettrez sans problème dans
l'ordre chronologique
bref julian assange à travers wikileaks
a révélé au monde des informations que
le gouvernement américain aurait bien
aimé garder secrète mais la presse
américaine a pris la défense de julian
assange le new york times les
associations de libertés civiles de
liberté de la presse de protection des
journalistes ont tous soutenu assange et
le soutiennent encore aujourd'hui disons
que ce qu'il a fait n'est pas l'oeuvre
d'un criminel mais d'un journaliste
amnesty a offert un prix à julian
assange pour le sarong renouveau de la
pratique journalistique
amnesty et le soutien aujourd'hui donc
dans ce combat pour la liberté de julian
assange c'est quand le combat pour
l'être humain qui est torturé et c'est
le combat au nom des libertés
fondamentales des droits humains liberté
de parole liberté de la presse s'est
inscrit dans l'histoire politique de la
france nous devons d'accorder l'asile
politique à julian assange passons
maintenant au sujet local pour finir
cette émission nous allons parler de la
ligne 18 du grand paris express qui doit
donc relier orly à versailles chantiers
en passant par le plateau de saclay lieu
de votre circonscription lors vous
réclamer l'abandon du tronçon ouest qui
relie donc saclay à versailles alors
quels sont vos raisons
cette ligne 18 c'est un enjeu
stratégique politique logistique
extrêmement forts qui s'est invitée de
façon quasi quotidienne dans mon mandat
depuis le début pour moi il y a deux
tronçons que je sais par la partie est
et la partie ouest la partie est pour
moi c'est celle qui va relier orly avant
d'enrôler et dans laquelle le tronçon le
plus important c'est celui qui va de
massy saclay
pour moi il est vital pour assurer
qu'ils autant que possible de de
transport pour aller desservir ce
plateau de saclay un plateau de saclay
sur lequel avec l'arrivée de
l'innovation avec l'arrivée de grandes
écoles ces inaugurations et quelques
jours de l'école normale supérieure
paris saclay vous avez une population
qui va tripler sur le plateau c'est
peut-être 100 milles à terme personnes
qui vont y travailler est un gros enjeu
de transport et les maires des communes
correspondante les maires dorcé de gif
de bure de massy sont tous très motivés
pour cette ligne arrive maintenant et la
partie ouest et c'est complètement
différent
ce sont beaucoup de chants des
territoires agricoles avec des
installations emblématique je pense la
ferme de monsieur van damme la ferme de
monsieur moreau et c'est
qu'ils sont protégés aujourd'hui
en partie par la loi la zone de
protection naturelle agricole et
forestière mais qui sont quand même
menacé d'être tronçonné si je puis dire
parce par cette partie là qui va passer
à travers champs oui il ya un enjeu de
protection des terres agricoles qui est
extrêmement fort
pour l'instant l'état s'est révélé
incapable d'assurer la confiance
localement rappelons que quatre
présidences successives la société du
grand paris ont été limogés
les concertations sur place
n'aboutissent pas les concertations avec
les agriculteurs n'aboutissent pas et
eux mêmes sont très opposés à cette
ligne les maires locaux aussi bien sur
le plateau de saclay côté essen ouest
peu côté yvelines sont opposés pour une
bonne partie à cette ligne et nous avons
ici une utilité qui n'est pas démontré
s'il s'agit et c'est le discours
officiel de relier le pôle d'innovation
de saclay au des pôles d'innovation
évinois comme satory excusez moi est ce
que c'est des gros flux de paul de
travail a pour le travail non les gros
flux de transport c'est entre domicile
et travail les flux de lieu de travail à
lui de travail sont beaucoup beaucoup
plus faible dans les projections on ne
voit pas aujourd'hui ce qui mènerait ce
à l'obligation d'un aussi lourd
transport entre entre le entre saclay et
saint-quentin entre saclay les yvelines
et c'est pourquoi j'appelle l'abandon de
ce projet surtout que
on a ici un
projet qui
soulève une opposition grandissante
épidermique sur place et dans lequel le
bon sens recommande simplement la
transition écologique aussi recommande
qu'on accorde dans ce qui peut être un
conflit entre des paysages à préserver
et un urbanisme extrêmement fort qu'on
accorde la priorité à l'environnement
les associations qui le qui sont
exactement sur cette ligne est pour moi
seul mot d'ordre sur la partie ouest
abandons 2 7 de ceux de cette section du
grand paris express
j'ajoute pour finir et ce sera mon
dernier mot le gens j'en dirais autant
du projet routier doublement de la rd 36
nous voulons derrière des 36 sur en gros
ce même trajet que le que le métro du
grand paris express
pour quoi faire
merci merci beaucoup
la nina avec nous dans l'hebdo politique
je rappelle que vous êtes le député de
la 5e circonscription de l'essonne nous
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de l'hebdo politiques
m'ont invité sera alors françois
durovray le président du conseil
départemental de l'essonne en attendant
très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
les politiques